y
[Música]
india superó la barrera de los 300.000
casos diarios de coronavirus además de
registrar un nuevo récord de fallecidos
en el país con 2 mil 104 muertes en la
última jornada se trata de un nuevo pico
de la segunda ola que atraviesa la
nación asiática en medio del colapso
sanitario
una semana antes de lo planeado joe
biden alcanza la meta de administrar 200
millones de dosis de la vacuna contra el
cob y 19 el 40 por ciento de los
estadounidenses han recibido al menos
una dosis sin embargo la inmunidad de
rebaño están lejos de alcanzarse porque
la vacunación no ha sido suficientemente
amplia en parte por el escepticismo del
fármaco
en el cuarto episodio de nuestra serie
toma pesqué viaje a las estrellas hoy
veremos el recorrido de los precursores
del yaque espacial en francia y cómo ha
marcado la historia entre ellos
precisamente esta pesca que este viernes
parte rumbo a la estación espacial
internacional como comandante del envío
conjunto de space ex y la nasa
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 y ríoblanco como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en india donde la pandemia nueva tregua
hoy el país asiático superó la barrera
de los 300.000 casos diarios de ccoo y
19 además de registrar un nuevo récord
de fallecidos con 2 mil 104 muertes en
las últimas 24 horas india es la segunda
nación más afectada por detrás de eeuu y
ha experimentado la mayor alza de los
contagios del mundo en las últimas
semanas en el marco de una segunda ola
de la pandemia del colapso sanitario
debido a la saturación de los hospitales
el mayor incremento de contagios en un
país del mundo desde el inicio de la
pandemia india reportó 314 mil 835 casos
de kobe 19 en las últimas 24 horas
sumando también un nuevo récord de
decesos con 2 mil 104 la propagación sin
precedentes del virus abrumado los
hospitales del país que luchan a
contrarreloj frente a la escasez de
oxígeno y la falta de camas en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos amigo
tiene 32 años tiene coronavirus aquí
y nos piden que nos trasladamos a la
segunda ola de la pandemia ha suscitado
temores ciudadanos sobre la capacidad de
los maltrechos servicios sanitarios para
hacer frente a la emergencia la gente
está realmente asustada estaba
aterrorizada la mayoría de la gente se
ha aislado en un encierro autoimpuesta
muchos atribuyen el impactante rebrote a
la doble variante india del patógeno más
contagiosa que las anteriores y que está
golpeando con más dureza
la población más joven pero también
critican al gobierno por la falta de una
respuesta contundente y la temprana
relajación de las medidas de
bioseguridad para frenar la propagación
del virus ante la gente quería salir de
las restricciones de todo el año la
gente quería volver al trabajo mientras
los expertos advertían incluso yo he
advertido que la inmunidad de rebaño es
un poco escurridiza en este momento y
que aún debemos ser muy cautelosos
el miércoles un tribunal de la capital
nueva delhi ordenó al gobierno que
desviar el oxígeno de uso industrial a
los hospitales con la esperanza de que
no sea demasiado tarde
eeuu ya ha administrado 200 millones de
dosis de la vacuna contra el coi 19
superando ampliamente la meta original
que la administración no en baden se
planeaba para sus primeros 100 días de
mandato que se cumplen la semana próxima
eeuu es el país con más casos de
coronavirus y muertes en el mundo con
más de 32 millones de positivos y 569
mil muertos veamos ahora el informe de
rosa pérez
eeuu el territorio con más muertes
causadas por el hobbit 19 parece empezar
a dejarlo atrás el país donde viven 328
millones de personas logro inocular 200
millones de dosis del fármaco contra el
coronavirus el 26 por ciento de la
población está totalmente vacunada
mientras que otro 40% recibió al menos
una dosis
el punto actual de la campaña que empezó
a principios de año ya superó las
expectativas de la propia casa blanca
biden había prometido alcanzar esta
cifra para sus primeros 100 días de
gobierno que se cumplen el 29 de abril y
no logramos twitter o llegamos a las 200
millones de dosis el 92º día de mi
mandato
sin embargo el 60% de los trabajadores
activos no está vacunado por lo que el
presidente estadounidense anunció
incentivos económicos a los empresarios
que permitan que sus empleados se
vacunen y recuperen en horas laborales
ningún trabajador estadounidense debería
perder ni un dólar de sueldo por elegir
cumplir con el deber ciudadano de
vacunarse no obstante la administración
de las vacunas no fue equitativa en el
territorio estadounidense especialmente
en áreas rurales donde aún hay
excepticismo al fármaco y para alcanzar
la inmunidad de rebaño es necesario que
al menos el 70 por ciento de la
población esté vacunada el ritmo de
vacunación también es desigual a escala
global las 200 millones de dosis
inoculadas en eeuu representan un 20 por
ciento de las administradas a nivel
mundial
pero mientras las grandes potencias
avanzan hacia la inmunización de la
población las regiones pobres del
planeta tienen grandes dificultades para
adquirir las vacunas precisamente en la
jornada de la cumbre iberoamericana del
miércoles en andorra pero en torno al
acceso equitativo y universal al fármaco
todos los mandatarios que asistieron a
la cumbre iberoamericana coincidieron en
una cosa la reivindicación del acceso
equitativo y universal a la vacuna
contra el jove 19 a pesar de proceder de
distintos espectros políticos los
líderes que participaron en el encuentro
semipresencial rechazaron el acceso
desigual a los fármacos y el retraso del
mecanismo kóvacs además luis arce
presidente de bolivia pidió la
liberación de las patentes las poderosas
trasnacionales farmacéuticas que tienen
patentes sobre los diagnósticos
medicamentos y vacunas deben liberarlas
y hacerlas de dominio público o emitir
autorizaciones voluntarias sin costo
para lograr un acceso real de parte de
todas las naciones sin excepción
recordando el carácter global de la
pandemia se apostó por la inmunización
mundial para acabar con el virus
debemos asumir además que nadie está a
salvo hasta que todos estemos a salvo y
por grande tenemos que avanzar hacia una
inmunización en vistas a la situación
españa se comprometió a donar entre un
5% y un 10% de sus inoculantes américa
latina'
por su parte la opep ee se señaló que
los países ricos poseen hasta cinco
veces más vacunas de las que necesitan y
advirtió sobre el aumento de contagios
en sudamérica pero en ningún sitio los
contagios son tan preocupantes como en
sudamérica donde los casos están
incrementando en casi todos los países
en américa latina es actualmente el
epicentro de la pandemia acumula
alrededor de 27 millones de contagios y
873 mil muertes
e instituciones católicas incluidas las
escuelas y universidades cerraron el
miércoles en todo haití en una protesta
de tres días para exigir la liberación
de cinco sacerdotes dos monjas y otras
tres personas secuestradas hace más de
una semana denuncian la pasividad de las
autoridades ante el preocupante aumento
de la violencia y los secuestros en el
país
su rapto ha conmocionado a haití hace
una semana y media sacerdotes y monjas
fueron secuestrados y aun lepe de ricky
son algunos de estos sacerdotes padecen
una diabetes aguda y necesitan
inyectarse insulina varias veces al día
estas personas que ya eran muy frágiles
antes de su secuestro se encuentran
ahora en una situación precaria en
youtube donde condición cree que la
iglesia católica del país lidera la
campaña para exigir su liberación
organizando un paro laboral al que se
han sumado muchas empresas escuelas y
universidades pero ya se les está
acabando la paciencia con un gobierno
que califican de incompetente
les esperaremos a ver si hay alguna
acción o reacción del gobierno sobre la
liberación de los sacerdotes y las demás
personas secuestradas si no hay reacción
todo el mundo verá claramente que el
gobierno irresponsable no tiene en
contra
en un país empobrecido y políticamente
inestable ha visto un aumento del 200
por ciento de los secuestros durante el
último año bajo una creciente presión el
presidente del país
yo en el mois ampliamente criticado
anunció el miércoles pasado una
remodelación del gobierno al menos dos
del grupo de secuestrados son franceses
un hombre que dice ser el líder de los
raptores se puso en contacto con una
emisora de radio local y anunció que
estaban solicitando a francia el dinero
de rescate haití se independizó de
francia en 1804 antes de verse obligado
a pagar enormes indemnizaciones a su
antiguo colonizador hoy cuando se
celebra el día mundial de la tierra el
presidente de estados unidos joe biden
busca liderar la lucha contra la crisis
climática con la organización de una
cumbre virtual que a partir de este
viernes este jueves 22 de abril reunirá
a 40 dirigentes internacionales entre
los que figuran los jefes de estado ruso
vladimir putin y chino xi jinping en
conversación con france24 orlando jorge
mera ministro de medioambiente de
republic
dominicanas explicó cómo hacer de la
lucha contra el cambio climático algo
atractivo para la economía de los países
veamos
definitivamente en la lucha contra el
cambio climático no solamente puede
partir de los gobiernos sino que se hace
necesario las estrategias y alianzas con
el sector privado indispensable para
poder trabajar juntos en soluciones a
estos problemas sin lugar a dudas que la
sociedad civil también juega un rol
importante en este aspecto y de tal
manera que en república dominicana que
sera
sede de la semana del cambio climático
ahora en mayo y también en agosto
esperamos que sea presencial y
semipresencial pues vamos a estar
trabajando de cara a fortalecer la
posición como país y como continente
hacia la cumbre del cambio climático
y más de 1700 personas fueron detenidas
ayer miércoles en rusia durante las
marchas convocadas en más de un centenar
de ciudades para exigir la liberación
del líder opositor alexéi navalni quien
se encuentra en un delicado estado de
salud en prisión
las marchas lograron reunir en todo
rusia a más de 14.000 personas según las
cifras proporcionadas por las
autoridades varias naciones de occidente
han anunciado sanciones a moscú si la
salud de navalny sigue empeorando
incluso si muere en prisión
en indonesia detectan una mancha de
petróleo donde ayer un submarino perdió
contacto el derrame podría significar
que hubo daños en el tanque de
combustible del navío o podría ser una
señal de la tripulación según afirmó la
marina de ese país
el submarino con 53 personas a bordo
estaba realizando un simulacro de
lanzamiento de torpedos en aguas al
norte de la isla de bali ayer por la
mañana y luego perdió todo tipo de
contacto países vecinos se
comprometieron a ayudar en la operación
de rescate
y mañana viernes despega a la estación
espacial internacional una tripulación
que incluye al astronauta francés toma
pesca el lanzamiento previsto para hoy
fue aplazado debido a las condiciones
climáticas pues que es uno de los 10
astronautas franceses que han ido al
espacio y este es su segundo viaje la
cuarta parte de nuestra serie toma
pesqué viaje a las estrellas está
dedicada a la historia de la exploración
francesa del espacio
desde finales de los 50 bajo el
liderazgo del general de gaulle francia
se convirtió en el tercer país en
establecer una agencia espacial la cn s
para lanzar su programa de cohetes y
enviar un animal al espacio luego llegó
el turno de los humanos un total de 10
astronautas han visto la tierra desde el
espacio una aguja no importa cuánto veas
fotos y películas de la tierra tomadas
desde el espacio cuando con tus propios
ojos te mueves hacia la portilla por
primera vez y la miras es guau
[Música]
así que me dijo si es como una joya es
más hermoso que el mejor cuadro pintado
por el mejor pintor de la historia y
después de que son sólo el caso el
pionero se llamó jean luc gestión en
1982 fue el primer europeo occidental en
abandonar la tierra un hecho de suma
importancia
[Música]
después jean-pierre en llegue fue el
primero en realizar una misión de larga
duración seis meses a bordo de la
estación mir y su esposa claudia que fue
la primera y única francesa en el
espacio pero la misión más notable para
un astronauta francés se dio en 1999 a
quinientos sesenta y nueve kilómetros de
la tierra el telescopio javier se
descompuso la nasa formó en sólo seis
meses una de las misiones con más
experiencia de la historia para salvar
el telescopio ese fue el tercer viaje de
jean françois clervoy el especialista en
brazos articulados mide 15 metros de
largo tiene hombro codo muñeca tuve dos
rondas de pilotaje para realizar
rotaciones y transacciones al mismo
tiempo en seis direcciones diferentes
captura el telescopio lo puse en la
bodega luego los días siguientes movía a
los compañeros atados al final del brazo
el día de navidad lancer telescopio al
espacio y después de algunas órbitas nos
llamaron discovery
houston el telescopio está 100%
operativo así que ese fue nuestro mejor
regalo de navidad el décimo y último
astronauta franceses thomas pesquet
ahora en su segunda estancia a bordo de
la estación espacial internacional sera
en comandar la
y por supuesto mañana dejamos a brindar
todos los detalles de este nuevo viaje
de pesca al espacio hasta aquí el
informativo de france 24 continúa con
nosotros muy buen día para todos
[Música]
france24 en español sigue